Ethanol has been a matter of intense
debate and lobbying for decades thanks
to the government support it enjoys.
Currently, the renewable fuel standard, or
RFS, requires refiners to blend ethanol
into their gasoline. This drives up
prices at the pump, but also at the
grocery store because it diverts
cropland from food production to fuel
production. Ranchers complain about the
effect on feed prices; environmentalists
object to ethanol's effect on
groundwater and greenhouse gas emissions. But the ethanol industry is politically
strong thanks to the clout of farmers and
Iowa's first-in-the-nation caucuses. In
early 2018, a refiner in Philadelphia
filed for bankruptcy, blaming the ethanol
mandate. The ethanol industry has pushed back on the Trump administration's plans
to weaken the RFS. Congress could end it
and force ethanol to compete in the free
market by passing legislation to wind
down the RFS over five years, and some
lawmakers have proposed a bill to do
just that. If this passed, it would mean
cleaner groundwater, cheaper gasoline, and cheaper food.
Do you think Congress will ever stand up to the farm lobby? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you would like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds,
and be sure to like and subscribe for more research and videos from AEI.